guys we're making some nice progress
here in under 30 hours we got almost a
hundred thousand comments to the
Copyright Office about how the DMCA is
being abused that is phenomenal we
cannot begin to say how thankful we are
for all of this and the great news is
it's working thanks to your efforts we
have secured two spots for the US
government round tables talking about
copyright in the future one in New York
City on May 2nd and 3rd and one in San
Francisco on May 12 and 13th the Araneta
voice needs to continue to be heard and
at these panels we can at least let the
government know of the abuse that's
going on and we have you guys to thank
for it and the other way we know it's
working we're having hit pieces put out
against us the copyright Alliance
released a piece claiming our movement
as a zombie apocalypse that's right we
are the zombies you hear that markiplier
Jeremy John's peanut butter gamer Andy
Signori team four star I hate everything
and all the other countless people that
been making your voices heard you have
no idea what you're talking about
you're just mindless zombies because
you're voiced your opinion clearly you
should be supporting the people that are
taking down videos without even having
to see them but this video is just a
review Carter it's protected under fair
use that's totally legal would you at
least watch the video before you claim
clearly they're the ones that know
what's going on and the second piece
from the industry called what we did a
cyber attack
I can only sum up our nefarious plans
with this clip from a 1990s movie the
planet apart yes
hack the planet indeed so now the public
voicing their concerns and their
opinions equals a cyber attack you
couldn't make this up if you tried so
yeah that gives you a little bit of an
idea about who we're going up against
and just how out of touch they are but
this is the best kind of news you can
get because it shows that we're getting
to them not only are they getting
worried but they're getting emotional
name-calling zombies this is what they
got right now but like we said before
we're in it for the long haul and
need to keep moving forward not only do
we need to continue to protect fair use
under the DMCA but make sure that this
new policy from the RIAA pushing for a
new amendment of takedown stay down
doesn't get any traction the recording
industry wants to change the DMCA so
that when one single upload gets flagged
by them any future piece of content
using that flagged portion is
automatically blocked from a site like
YouTube so let's say Fox blocks and
upload up their newest x-men movie on
YouTube does that mean any footage used
for a review or anything like that is
gonna be taken down it's gonna result in
your channel being destroyed we don't
know it's possible it will only affect
full uploads which they're in the right
to block but we're giving these
companies that have clearly shown they
like to abuse this system even more
power and that's not good so what can
you do to help well the cool thing is
fight for the future has decided to
leave the DMCA abuse comments open until
these meetings were going to have ramped
up so keep sending your comments and
personal stories about the DMCA abuse
and we'll make sure that it gets to the
Copyright Office on top of that we want
to remove one of the counter points that
the movies and recording industries keep
using with no factual evidence and we
gotta prove them wrong on this
they say reviews parodies covers remixes
Let's Plays those are hurting their
sales we know that's not true me and a
lot of other producers have gotten
countless emails of people saying that
they checked out a movie or a TV show
based on our material or even that they
completely forgot about a movie until it
was reviewed let's give them some hard
numbers if you have ever bought a movie
video game song television episode our
complete season a piece of software or
anything else based upon someone's
review let's play cover remix or video
on YouTube let us know for example Greg
Sestero who played Marc in the room he
told us that our review of the movie the
room actually got a lot of attention on
and right now he's in the process of
filming a movie about that movie that's
what happens when you get a lot of
attention looking at this it creates new
media and it creates jobs it does all
these wonderful things and that's what
we got to get them to know
just click the link below and tell us
what you bought and what video you saw
that inspired you to purchase it guys we
said from the beginning we're in it for
the long haul and it looks like you guys
are too honestly this is probably just
the beginning of this but already we're
making progress we're making our voices
heard we are not going to be quiet about
this and you guys have made that
possible and if you're just joining into
all this even follow the where's the
fair use movement or anything like that
there's links below to show you what
we're talking about copyright law is
going to be changed but with your help
we can change it for the better and
protect the Internet thanks everybody
for your support and this is Doug Walker
still asking where's the fair use